es para ti va a mis espaldas como puedes
ver empiezan a congregarse distintos
señores el candidato andrés arados
específicamente la sede electoral del
órgano comicial equipo de igual forma
también en la sede electoral desde el
órgano comicial en guayaquil y de igual
forma también el tribunal contencioso
electoral es que el candidato andrés
zarautz ha pedido que accionar y
presentarse de manera pacífica como lo
puedes ver a mis espaldas para reclamar
lo que ha sido el pedido de peritaje al
sistema informático del consejo nacional
electoral él ha dicho también ha llamado
a la observación internacional para que
esté muy pendiente en cuanto a lo que se
ha pedido por parte de los organismos de
la fiscalía y la contraloría debes tomar
en cuenta que esto es considerado
también como una infracción grave y de
igual forma también el consejo nacional
electoral su presidenta ha dicho hoy que
quieren tomarse por asalto al consejo
nacional electoral haciendo eco de las
fuerzas políticas en este sentido la
presidenta del consejo nacional
electoral había emitido un
pronunciamiento en las redes sociales
donde ella básicamente
las funciones el estado la fiscalía y la
contraloría a no hacerse eco de
intereses partidistas gustado justamente
en qué consiste el proceso de peritaje
que pidieron la fiscalía y la
contraloría
pero básicamente el peritaje al sistema
informativo consiste en retirar
computadores para identificar así a
usuarios las configuraciones del sistema
informático de que hace funcionamiento
de las selecciones de igual forma
también crear verificar los perfiles
verificar también los permisos asignados
igual forma ha dicho que intenta
verificar las actas de inconsistencia de
igual forma han dicho que se preservará
las bases de datos que administran el
sistema electoral pero esto también se
ha pedido un plazo más el informe
emitido por la fiscalía y la contraloría
ha pedido un tiempo para realizar este
peritaje no el día de hoy como se
establecía a las 7 y 30 de la mañana
sino en una fecha que no se ha
especificado por pronto se esperan más
concentraciones de igual forma
concentraciones de en esta zona que
anteriormente estuvo tomada por el
representante de movimientos indígenas y
ahora es ocupada por los seguidores del
candidato andrés zarautz